[music]
shop
[music] for a
long time the inhabitants of the southwestern historical
ancient Russian lands called themselves
Russian and Orthodox
design and fit
18 year olds
[music]
just
then 12 kilometers of glazing beads stand by bm
pashki and who are shawnee  the ruble is
incomprehensible glory to ukraine but
in everything it’s clear different hello say the
word glade to
our comrades close among whom are not
only colleagues friends former colleagues
but also relatives people connected with us by
blood family ties
you’re a fine fellow drag this is what we
wanted to expect from you on the beach we
caught Russians  nafov basement in our
yard with machine guns with all he military
timurs pancake
like onatob fleet
ukraine freemont
torch
notice our tram pro and ficus pidaras
also I want to give the highest appreciation to the
actions of russian soldiers and officers
they act courageously
professionally
heroically
broke boys broke down
can be dragged to russia  back and you
eat where you are going
your ass  acha unit
you met during this time the Nazis and
Bandera
[music] of
Bukovina
for which you
passed when
transferring me for fun to run around the
backpack decided not to wait until 6 if they
[ __ ] remind me I will be credited
three tanks hit and p&id
offshoot of Russia hairpin dam
kids will come in handy in  housekeeping
[music]
until the
very canossa tow on them to improve the van
and
here is a
frightened martynyuk martyniuk and
three tanks
and already honored the skin of the mousse or you yourself are
Belarus that you came given whether I could
who the Ukrainian damn I will offer you to
lay down the [ __ ] weapons until we
came you didn’t get in and the lobby
that is, I live here, I live
everything
[music]
here is the smelt
rather that they will return
to us and badly go to the
bidding
crookers back to Ramadan and let them go instead of a
wig Utah
people